a new social media site boasts that its
user base has increased 47
each month for the past year the number
of users on january 1st of last year was
50 050 000 which expression below gives
the total number of new users in
thousands that were added through month
n of the past year where one is less
than or equal to n which is less than or
equal to 12 and they give some choices
of expressions for the total number of
new users that were added through month
n
and i encourage you to now pause this
video and try to think about which of
these expressions actually show that
that gives that value
well to tackle it i'm going to make a
little bit of a table here
so let's say we have
month month
and then we have
users
so starting users so users at the start
and then let's think about the users
added i want to put give myself some
space to work with and then users at the
end of the month
users at the end of the month so in one
month or in month one
which is january we can assume
we started with 50 000 users they want
us to write the expression in thousands
so we started with 50 000 users and how
many did we add well we added 47 percent
of 50 000 so 50 times 47
so times
0.47 so how many do we end with well 50
plus 50 times 0.47
that's going to be 50
times i'll do the 15 green
times 1.47
50 times 1.47 if this isn't clear just
think about this this you could rewrite
as 50 times 1. so 50 times 1 plus 50
times 0.47 that's going to be 50 times 1
plus 0.47
1 plus
1 plus 0.47 or 1.47 so it's going to be
this thing right over here so now let's
go to month 2.
let's go to month 2.
we start with what we ended the last
month so 50 i could just copy and paste
this actually let me just do that
so that's what so copy
and paste
so that's what we start with now what
are we going to add
well we're going to add that this what
we started with times 0.47
times
0.47 and so what are we going to end
with well if you sum these two and you
could write this as you could write it
this way
this is going to be
this thing
times
times 1.47
or
or we could just write this as 50 times
1.47
squared and you might start seeing a
pattern now let's go to month three
so month three what do we start the
month with we start the month with
this thing let me copy and paste this
so copy and paste
we start
with that what do we add
we're going to take that and we're going
to multiply it times 47
we're going to multiply it times
0.47
and so what are we going to end up with
we're going to have this times 1
plus this times 0.47
that is going to be
equal to
that
that times
times 1.47
1.47 or we could just write this as 50
to
the third power so what's the pattern
here
well in each month we're going to be
starting with 50 times 1.47
to a power one less than the month in
the third month the power here is two
and the second month the power here is
1. in the first month the power here
you don't see it but you could view this
as times
1.47 to the zero power so first month
zero power second month
first second month you have the first
power third month you have the second
power over here so if we're thinking
about the nth month
if we think about the nth month this is
going to be
times 1.47
1.47 to the n minus 1 power
n minus 1 power is what we're going to
start the month with now what are we
going to add in the nth month what's
going to be that times 47
so it's going to be
let me just copy and paste that
so
let me just paste that so it's going to
be that
times 47
so times
times 0.47
and then what are we going to end with
when you add these two things you are
going to get
you are going to get 50. i'll just do it
in the right colors instead of copying
paste it you're going to get 50 times
1.47
times
1.47 to the nth power
to the nth power
so let's think about how we can come up
with the expression for the total number
of new users and thousands that were
added through
through
month n so there's a couple of ways to
think about it
you could say well how many total new
you how many total users did we have at
the end of month n well at the end of
month end we had that many
and then how many did we have at the
beginning of the year well we had 50 000
so how many total new users did we add
through month n
so we finished with this much
so we finished with actually let me just
write it down
so we just
let me just
so we finished with that much
and let me paste that so that's what we
finished with and we started with 50 000
users
we started with 50 000 users so this is
essentially how many we added through
month n now do any of our expressions
look like that
well no not quite if this one had a
minus 50 right over here if that said
minus 50 then that would have done the
trick but this doesn't do it
and none of the others really seem to
either have this form or seem to be
something that would be very easy to
manipulate in this form so that's one
way to do it but that's not one of our
choices so what's another way of
thinking about it well we could
literally just add how many new users we
added month by month so we literally
could just add
all of these things right over here
we could literally just add all of these
things right over here
and before i so let's see we could
literally just add
all of all of these terms but let me
simplify it a little bit so what are
some common factors that we see in all
of these well we see they all have a 50
they all have a 50 and they all have
something being multiplied by 0.47 so
let's factor out a 0.47 and a 50. so
let's factor that out so this is going
to be equal to if we were to sum all of
this up it's going to be 0.47
times 50
and then what's left over
times so in the first month if you
factor those two things out you're going
to just be left with a one in the second
month if you factor out the 50 and the
0.47 you're left with 1.47
in the third month
in the third month if you factor that
and that out you're left with
1.47 squared and we're going to go all
the way to the nth month if you factor
out that and that you're left with
1.47 to the n minus 1 power so which of
those expressions look like that well
this is exactly this is exactly the
second expression right over here
this is exactly with what we came up
with
and we're done